una morsa y un pingüino juegan a
perseguirse el pingüino nada 9 metros a
la izquierda y luego regresa hacia la
derecha otros 12 metros el pingüino nada
un tiempo total de 8 segundos
cuál es la velocidad promedio del
pingüino durante el juego
cuál es la rapidez promedio del pingüino
durante el juego responde usando un
sistema coordinado donde a la derecha es
positivo redondea a dos cifras decimales
pausa en el vídeo y traten de encontrar
el resultado por su cuenta
ahora vamos a resolverlo juntos la
velocidad promedio es una cantidad
vectorial a veces pueden ver escritos
los vectores así con una flecha encima
pero cuando son vectores en una
dimensión a veces no se indica nada en
especial pues los signos negativos y
positivos indican la dirección del
vector esto es igual al desplazamiento
dividido entre el tiempo que duró el
recorrido para encontrar el
desplazamiento nos dicen que el pingüino
nada 9 metros hacia la izquierda y
recuerden que nos indican que debemos
usar un sistema coordinado en donde la
dirección a la derecha es positiva
como el pingüino nado a la izquierda
esta cantidad será negativa menos 9
metros + 12 metros a la derecha
todo esto dividido entre el tiempo que
es 8 segundos menos 9 + 12 es igual a 3
positivo
dividido entre 8 y las unidades son
metros por segundo pero como nos piden
el resultado con dos cifras decimales
vamos a escribir el resultado en
decimales 3 entre 80 puntos 375 pero nos
piden solo dos cifras decimales así que
lo redondeamos a 0.38 metros por segundo
esta es la velocidad promedio del
pingüino durante el juego
aproximadamente 0.38 metros por segundo
ahora vamos a calcular la rapidez
promedio del pingüino de nuevo pausa en
el vídeo y traten de calcular esto vamos
a resolverlo juntos
la rapidez promedio es igual a la
distancia entre el tiempo en esta
ocasión no usamos el desplazamiento sino
la distancia y al usar la distancia no
nos interesa conocer la dirección del
movimiento solo nos interesa la magnitud
a distancia es igual a 9 metros + 12
metros podemos ver esto como los valores
absolutos de estas cantidades de aquí
dividimos esto entre el tiempo esto es
igual a 21 entre 8 metros por segundo 8
cabe dos veces en 21 y quedan 5 octavos
5 octavos en decimal es 0.625 esto es
igual a 2.625 pero como nos piden la
respuesta con dos cifras decimales
redondeamos esto aproximadamente igual a
dos puntos 63 metros por segundo con
esto terminamos y nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo